[Musica]
l'impronta
che fame
c'è qualcuno
pronto
sì
mi sto aspettando adesso
non mi vorrai mica rubare il pane
[Musica]
internet nino
andiamo con tornare anita che cosa era
lo store umore che non è sentito il
rumore strano no non c'è niente di
strano sto solo facendo il bagno vedi
tutto che è
sì perché che cosa vista di nascondendo
niente non sono ascoltato niente hai la
faccia di una che nasconde qualcosa sta
nascondendo proprio niente perché pensi
che ti sta nascondendo qualcosa
non ne sono tanto sicuro poi vuole
tornare a mangiare posso tornare a
mangiare
wow e quando mi ricapita un'occasione
così ciao
per fortuna vitale che è cascato e se ne
ha dato
deve scoprire che è successo di nuovo ha
trasformato di nuovo in una sirena ma
chi è stato questa volta non ho raccolto
nessun ciondolo non ho toccato niente
non ho fatto niente
una cosa è certa è meglio che glielo
tengono a scotto vi ricordate la scorsa
volta le sue soluzioni
è meglio che non lo sappia anche perché
non è colpa mia io stavo solo facendo il
bagno il problema è che le bolle stato
svanendo si stanno scoppiando quando
tutte le donne scoppieranno vitale vedrà
la coda che sto tenendo nascosta qua
che cosa faccia fare nasconderla
aggiungerò altro bagno schiuma così
forse
aumenteranno le bolle
guarda che ho sentito tutto adesso mi
spieghi quello del successo va bene ma
non ti sto nascondendo nulla ho solo
detto che andavo ad aggiungere un po di
bagnoschiuma per fare un po più di bolle
vedi
ma tu che cosa hai sentito esattamente
ho sentito che mi stava nascondendo
qualcosa e poi sento anche
una puzza di pesce che cos'è puzza di
pesce
forse dalle finestre dal mare
mi sembra che non stai butto bene sai
senti cosa estrarre se il giocatore tra
le porte e mezzo vai a mangiare qualcosa
di così o no non ci casco più che ogni
volta mi mandi in cucina a mangiare poi
dopo mi nascondi qualcosa adesso mi
racconti che cosa è successo
cos'è quella cosa verde lee kai sulla
gamba
no niente il mio costume da bagno
questo per celeste da bagno non vedi beh
allora se non mi stai nascondendo niente
vorrà dire che svuotato la vasca una
volta svuotarla tutta l'acqua non ci
sarà più niente da nascondere giusto no
no non svuotarlo potrebbero essere molto
pericoloso non ne volesse apcom più
scomparendo no i freni studies portare
l'acqua ei 28 invece figli ho detto bene
come successo ha
detto che lo togliamo
subito
doveva pur notiamo più
che cosa è successo qui è rimasta un po
di
un'altra volta sirena di nuovo
sì lo so per questo che non volevo
dirtelo o
dove è stata colpa mia questa volta però
ma dobbiamo trovare una soluzione perchè
altrimenti non potrà più camminare come
pazzo non possono che sia fuori dall
acqua
però meglio se andavo in cucina a
mangiare e mi stavo ei
30 e
si si si si certo c'è scusa stavo stato
giusto fra pensiero certo che ti voglio
aiutare
però un po di aria fresca
alla fine sono utili queste
è sentito cos'era
poi controllare sì sì sì sì
c'è qualcuno
si
è come dio ho trovato questa tavoletta
qui con un messaggio per te un messaggio
per te per me ma da parte di chi non lo
so
se le gambe indietro vorrai tutte le mie
prove superare dovrai se fallirà e mai
più camminare potrai un nuovo cattivo
non so chi sia ma ci aspettano delle
nuove sfide e soprattutto tutte le sfide
verranno con la coda da sirena sarà
molto difficile questa volta non come
quelle del lupo mannaro vi ricordate
questa volta non potrò usare le gambe
nei challenger si fanno sempre più
difficili ma come farai a dormire questa
notte non puoi mica uscire dall'acqua no
non posso uscire dall'acqua proprio
dormire qua non nuovo schema bagni non è
propria scomoda però non è neanche tanto
comoda devo dire ma è l'unica soluzione
lui lasciato un mi piace per portarci
fortuna e queste nuove challenge lascio
ad un mi piace qui sotto che cosa faceva